grand débat de cette émission sens
publique un débat qui est consacrée au
douzième jour de guerre en ukraine alors
c'est difficile évidemment de faire un
point sur la situation exacte ce qu'on
sait c'est que les lignes de front ont
peu évolué au cours des dernières 24
heures la capitale kiev reste encore
pour combien de temps sous contrôle
ukrainien tout comme visiblement karki
jeu tout comme visiblement marioupol
malgré d'intenses bombardements russes
et en même temps on sait que s'ouvre de
nouveaux pourparlers qui est cette
proposition de corridors on va faire le
point sur tous et tous ces enjeux bien
évidemment pendant cette dernière partie
de notre émission met tout de suite le
point sur cette journée de guerre par
quentin calmes mais ils sont des
centaines à fuir les combats dans la
région de kiev ces civils fuient les
bombardements au nord ouest de la
capitale ukrainienne désormais presque
encerclée par les troupes russes femme
enfant est né leur évacuation des points
les plus chauds du conflit fait l'objet
d'âpres négociations au douzième jour de
la guerre en ukraine des pourparlers ont
repris entre négociateurs russes et
ukrainiens les troisième du genre avec
pour objet central la question des
couloirs humanitaires la russie propose
depuis ce matin de créer des corridors
autour de quatre villes parmi les plus
durement touchées par les combats
certains de ces couloirs mène vers la
biélorussie un sigle à la russie cette
proposition a été sèchement refusé par
les autorités ukrainiennes et également
dénoncé ce midi par le chef de l'état
les couloirs humanitaires faits sont
clairs cc la possibilité de faire sortir
ces femmes et ces hommes la russie
plaide pour faire des couloirs
humanitaires vers la russie
ne connais pas beaucoup d'ukrainiens qui
est envie d'aller se réfugier en russie
c'est une hypocrisie et donc c'est un
artefact de communication que je
réprouve et les associations qui font un
travail formidable acteur pour en citer
une la croix rouge internationale et
tant d'autres vous diront que les
couloirs humanitaires ne sont pas
forcément les solutions qu'elle préfère
de son côté dans un nouveau message
diffusé aujourd'hui volodymyr zelensky a
appelé les occidentaux à prendre de
nouvelles sanctions envers la russie
comme avec le boycott du pétrole russe
si l'invasion se poursuit et que la
russie d'abandonner pas ses plans contre
l'ukraine
or une nouvelle série de sanctions est
nécessaire de nouvelles sanctions contre
la guerre et pour la paix oui cet après
midi justement joe biden s'est entretenu
avec ses homologues français allemands
et britanniques afin de discuter d'une
nouvelle salve de sanctions envers la
russie
alors pour débattre de la situation en
ukraine ce soir j'accueille sylvie
matelly bonsoir êtes économiste
directrice adjointe de l'iris alors je
précise à votre expectat heures que seul
institut de relations internationales et
stratégiques à vos côtés christian
carion soir christian bon journaliste au
point radio notre-dame spécialiste des
questions internationales
kevin et monier vous êtes maître de
conférence à l'institut français de
géopolitique et spécialiste du
cyberespace russophone ça on soirée puis
j'accueille aussi par écran interposé
frédéric charillon vous êtes professeur
de relations internationales à
l'université clermont auvergne est à
l'essai que vous venez de publier guerre
d' influence les états à la conquête des
esprits et puis bien sûr laetitia cru
pas qu'ils restent avec nous jusqu'à la
fin de cette émission alors on va
aborder la question bien sûr des
sanctions va aborder la question des
corridors humanitaires celle de la
guerre de communication suisse que ce
que veut la dgac outils mais avant
j'aimerais quand même qu'on essaie de
faire un point sur la situation je le
disais tout à l'heure nous sommes au
douzième jour de guerre et kiev kharkiv
sont toujours l'ukrainienne est ce que
c'est une surprise pour vous christian
carion alors là il faut pas faire les
malins aujourd'hui où on voit les choses
rétrospectivement le début a surpris
tout le monde parce qu'on s'attendait
éventuellement à une guerre limitée mais
pas à une guerre totale la surprise elle
est là et au bout d'une dizaine de jours
on a vu clairement quand on regarde la
carte de l'ukraine une mâchoire de
crocodile s'installer avec un max
hilaire au sud tout le long de la mer la
mer d'azov et maintenant jusqu'à au
dessin c'est à dire la frontière de la
moldavie donc évidemment danger pour la
moldavie et puis au nord une mâchoire
qui part d'une base qui inclut karkhiv
qui rejoint t virus est 5e donc on voit
bien que toutes là partie orientale la
rive orientale du fleuve dniepr est visé
par les russes qui de temps en temps
d'ailleurs on un bombardement à l'ouest
comme ils l'ont fait à vinnitsa ont
rappelé qu'ils peuvent frapper à tout
moment donc c'est une guerre totale et
de ce point de vue là la suite
malheureusement si elle n'est pas
prévisible ne peut pas être vu de façon
très optimiste du point de vue de
l'intérêt des populations civiles et du
point de vue de la souveraineté de
l'état qui s'appelle le crâne bien sûr
frédéric charillon je m'adresse à vous
par écran interposé je le disais est ce
que pour vous la russie continue de
sous-estimer l'ukraine en tout cas la
résistance des ukrainiens
en tout cas il ya une lutte sans doute
une résistance à laquelle là aussi c'est
un débat et du coup la russie semble
maintenant être lancé dans une fuite en
avant mais bien compris que la dîmière
poutine ne voulait pas ne pouvait pas
perdre ce baril ce baril s'annonce plus
compliqué qu'il ne souhaitait alors
d'abord parce que effectivement il ya
cette résistance ukrainien il a créé il
avril à créer il a en tout cas très
fortement ancrés et institutionnalisés
et répandu dans le monde une entité
ukrainienne si le but de va et vient
continu été de dire l'ukraine ça
n'existe pas c'est pas un vrai pays
c'est la même il est temps qu'elle
revienne dans le giron
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que c'est que c'est raté peut-être at-il
aussi sous-estimé d'ailleurs les
réactions internationales et peut-être
des réactions notamment occidentales ce
qui est tout à fait étonnant aujourd'hui
c'est que il a commencé en disant notre
intention n'est pas d'envahir l'ukraine
mais il a envahi l'ukraine ensuite nous
sommes un seul peuple or aujourd'hui
c'est ce peuple qui est qui est visée à
les nations unies ont décompté plusieurs
centaines de morts dont plusieurs
enfants aujourd'hui et il avait promis
de ne pas s'en prendre aux civils ils
sont possibles donc ça cause ça pose un
double problème
d'abord celui de la parole
de du pouvoir russe aujourd'hui dans
toute négociation
et puis ça pose un deuxième problème qui
est cette fuite en avant se dire qu'on a
l'impression que plus la russie elle
sera isolée sur le plan diplomatique et
sur le plan économique plus lui restera
la force et la fuite en avant dans la
force pour tenter le fait accompli sur
le terrain et on a bien vu que dans ce
type de situation les visuels n'avait
pas compté beaucoup et plus ça dure
d'une certaine façon qui ne venaient
plus ce conflit dure plus la situation à
l'avenir et même si la russie mettez la
main sur le cren promet d'être compliqué
parce qu'il faudra occuper ce pays on
pourra pas se contenter de mettre en
place un régime fantoche il faudra
occuper militairement pour venir à bout
de deux sets et résistance de la
population oui absolument même si le
rouleau compresseur russe finit par
passer on reprendre les mots du du chef
d'état major français les mots qu'il a
utilisé je crois hier dans une interview
au monde et ce rouleau compresseur russe
pourrait finir par passer on voit que
les ukrainiens perdent du terrain même
si de manière beaucoup plus lente que ce
qu'on aurait pu imaginer au départ il y
aura ensuite une situation
insurrectionnelle
de manière assez évidente on voit que
les américains sont déjà en train de
préparer l'éventualité d'un gouvernement
ukrainien en exil il y à fort à parier
qu'il y ait déjà des réflexions très
avancées pour armer une résistance armée
une insurrection qui aura derrière elle
si je veux dire le poids économique
technologique de tout l'occident alors
que la russie elle finira cette conquête
complètement épuisée avec une armée qui
on le voit a été complètement laminé de
manière complètement inattendue par par
l'ukraine si je m'étais dit toujours sur
cette première douzaine de jours de
guerre est ce que vous diriez que les
sanctions mises en place
ont perturbé les plans du kremlin dans
sa volonté d'une guerre rapide
complètement et surtout alors est-ce
qu'elles ont perturbé dans sa volonté
d'une guerre rapide c'est difficile à
dire simplement je pense que vladimir
poutine
et c'est ce que disait frédéric
charillon ne s'attendait pas à une
réaction internationale aussi rapide et
aussi coordonnée il était déjà habitué
aux sanctions et rappelez vous il ya une
dizaine de jours on pensait que ils
avaient tous les moyens pour limiter
l'impact des sanctions parce que déjà
habitués parce que déjà avait déjà mis
en place depuis 2014 tout à fait depuis
la crimée un certain nombre
d'instruments qui lui permettrait de
contourner ces sanctions on se rend
compte qu'en fait il n'avait absolument
rien pour vous donner juste un chiffre
des conséquences économiques de ces
sanctions aujourd'hui où en 2014 pour
acheter un dollar il vous fallait entre
30 et 40 roubles aujourd'hui on est à
100 40 roubles donc c'est énormissime et
l'autre contre l'exécution de son plan
de l'invasion de l'ukraine vous pensez
que les sanctions et on peut lui ont
porté tort donc aux hommes n'ont pas
directement dans son plan mais par
contre c'est vrai qu'elle oblige
aujourd'hui à penser différemment la
suite du conflit alors avec deux deux
choses qui se télescopent télescope en
fait l'impact des sanctions immédiat sur
le rouble et la valeur du rouble et il
est obligé de réagir à ça et puis d'un
autre côté des sanctions qui n'ont pas
encore touché le gaz et le pétrole et on
voit que c'est bien la limite parce que
c'est les yeux à qui la semaine dernière
a estimé que depuis un mois grâce à
l'augmentation du prix du pétrole la
russie gagner 100 millions de dollars
l'état russe gagner 100 millions de
dollars par jour
rien que sur ses exportations à
destination de l'europe et de l'union
européenne donc on voit que qu'elle perd
en parité de coûts roubles dollars
gars
complètement parce qu'on voit quand même
un président russe aujourd'hui qui prend
des mesures assez drastiques on l'a vu
demander à ces entreprises de régler ses
factures en roubles ce qui veut dire ne
pas payer enfin puisque le rouble ne
vaut rien donc on s'aperçoit que ça pèse
s'apaisent quand même et surtout ce qui
pèse encore plus c'est au delà de la
coordination des états occidentaux ce
qui pèse encore plus pour les russes
c'est que les acteurs privés les
entreprises se retirent massivement de
russie ça c'est une grande première
anticipant des lendemains très très
difficile et pas seulement pour des
questions d'image de marque on voit
également que la chine bien que
soutenant la russie est quand même assez
regardantes sur le soutien économique
parce que ça pourrait lui coûter très
très cher
christian makarian le président annonce
qui a appelé aujourd'hui deux nouveaux
j'allais dire à ce qu'on sanctionne le
gaz et le pétrole russe ça une chance de
voir le jour ou jamais alors
maintenant des études de plus en plus
poussée qui sont faites qui tendent à
prouver qu'on peut imaginer une
cessation de la dépendance par rapport
au gaz il y aura une facture bien sûr
élevé mais enfin quand même regardons ce
qui s'est passé en une douzaine de jours
l'allemagne a opéré un virage quand même
spectaculaire sur ses fondamentaux de
défense nationale ce qui au passage
n'était n'aurait pas forcément pu se
produire si angela merkel était encore
là je pense que ça joue un rôle la
transition olaf scholz a joué un rôle
parce qu'on est là merkel qui je
rappelle par les russes et il faut aussi
rappeler que monsieur poutine parle
parfaitement allemand et elle avait une
tendance quand même aménagé et tout le
temps la russie l'allemagne a franchi un
cran papa sur la question du pétrole
celle ci l'a répété cet après-midi par
oui vous couple christian et puis vous
nous répondez après l'approvisionnement
de l'europe en énergie pour la
production de chaleur la mobilité
l'électricité et l'industrie ne peut pas
être assurée autrement pour le moment
c'est signé du chancelier exact pour le
moment pour le moment assez l'importance
est pour le moment mais oui parce que
parce que il ya beaucoup d'études qui
sont faites et les industriels allemands
sont en pointe là dessus pour évidemment
une transition rapide et autre chose
regardez déjà l'approvisionnement par le
nord stream 2 le deuxième gazoduc
est interrompue si ça dure de la russie
ça viendra il peut y avoir autre chose
et c'est un enjeu d'une redistribution
géopolitique énorme et à d'autres
approvisionnements par le sud du caucase
par exemple mais aussi bien sûr le
fameux gaz liquéfié américain tout ça
pourrait être une très bonne affaire
pour les états unis qui étonnamment
reste quand même assez en retrait sur
cette crise ukrainienne soyez honnête
par rapport aux européens qui sont très
en avant quand il ya deux surprises y en
a pas qu'une la première surprise c'est
que les européens sont étonnamment
combatif et réactif parce que ça
aujourd'hui encore l'union européenne a
décidé même si c'est symbolique d'ouvrir
les négociations d'adhésion de l'ukraine
aujourd'hui à l'union européenne de
l'ukraine de la moldavie et de la
géorgie c'est évidemment symbolique
puisqu'il faudra un temps très long pour
y parvenir mais enfin c'est quand même
significatif
et puis la deuxième surprise c'est que
les états unis évidemment reste
relativement en retrait par rapport à la
gravité extrême de cette crise alors
même que les renseignements américains
depuis le début était excellent autant
qu'ils étaient nuls épouvantail
sur l'afghanistan et la retail la garde
civile matelly est ce qu'il reste des
sanctions à prendre dans la besace
j'allais dire des occidentaux au delà de
cette question du pétrole et du gaz est
ce qui a encore des choses qu'on peut
crantée pour faire plier la trinité
oublier la russie très clairement il je
vais citer qu'un exemple le système
swift qui ne sanctionne à ce jour que
cette banque et pas les principales donc
on s'aperçoit quand on a protégé par
tous les moyens le pétrole et le gaz et
ça va très très loin y compris sur le
choix des sanctions financières et
autres je pense qu'on a un yves quand
même au bout de la logique et qu'il va
falloir aller plus loin alors par de
nouvelles sanctions sur le pétrole ou
par des sanctions sur le pétrole et le
gaz j'en sais rien mais il va falloir
aller plus loin et pour rebondir sur ce
que vous venez de dire moi je pense que
les états unis joe biden administration
byden s'est pris deux claques en
arrivant au pouvoir la première ça a été
atteinte à la démocratie
et finalement la prise de conscience que
la démocratie était fragile aux états
unis et que quatre ans de donald trump
avait fait beaucoup de mal mais ça on
sur le câble t'as fait ça explique
beaucoup de choses et le deuxième la
deuxième chose qu'on est en train de
réaliser c'est la perte de confiance et
de crédit dont dispose et les états unis
après 20 ans d'erreurs stratégiques
majeures et de mensonges il faut le dire
sur les renseignements américains sur
les renseignements dont disposaient les
américains qui se sont avérées
extrêmement juste moi je me souviens une
semaine avant l'invasion de l'ukraine
par la russie le new york times douter
de ces informations en disant vous nous
avait déjà fait le coup en 2003 donc on
est dans une situation quand même très
très c'est pour ça qu'ils laissent les
européens à la manoeuvre c'est plus
prudent pour kevin et c'est votre avis
aussi ils sont un peu de démonétiser
les américains
parfaitement d'accord sur le fait que le
coût de la fiole d'armes de destructive
d'armes chimiques en 2003 a laissé des
traces et d'ailleurs on voit aujourd'hui
que les russes sont en train de forger
défaut narratif qui se base sur cet
imaginaire puisque nous avons découvert
avec mon équipe il ya par exemple trois
jours que le comte télégramme de la
centrale nucléaire de the bridge ya donc
qui est qui a été prise par les par les
russes il ya peu de temps avait commencé
à émettre des messages en russe déjà
remerciant les russes l'arrivée pour
libérer la centrale etc et de dire nous
avons des preuves que nous sommes en
train que les ukrainiens sont en train
de construire une arme nucléaire pardon
que les minimaux nîmes est ce que c'est
pas dans la grande tradition autrefois
soviétique d'inventer que des partis
frères avaient appelé que des mouvements
et les solutions sylviane mrm pays c'est
vrai mais ce qui est frappant c'est que
le natif ukrainienne est
considérablement supérieure
on va virer qu'une incarnation parce que
justement regarder les deux incarnations
dans un cas on à volodimir zelensky dans
l'autre cas on lave la dîmière poutine
de bas de gamme ça se passe de
commentaire donc lequel des deux avec
lequel des deux avez-vous le plus envie
de dialoguer franchement et hélène ce
qui à travers son implication
personnelle puisque encore une fois tout
le monde le sait il risque sa peau ni
plus ni moins à donner un visage et un
langage à tout un peuple à tout un
peuple est d'accord avec vous en fait
j'avais exactement cette lecture pour
vraiment pour être très honnête de la
situation et de la guerre de
communication et d'image parce que c'est
une guerre de clans c'est
qu'effectivement g20 ce qui avait avait
un atout et on y reviendra tout à
l'heure mais c'est vrai qu'en fait il
faut comprendre aussi comment est le
monde il ya une étanchéité entre deux
système informationnel et
communicationnel donc oui c'est un héros
pour les occidentaux oui mais très
honnêtement pour les russes les chinois
il ya toute une partie du monde des
indiens je ne crois pas que volodymyr
zemsky soit le héros de tous ces gens
parce que des réseaux sociaux notamment
ont été coupées en russie on peut le
rappeler très récemment twitter facebook
il ya sept lois sur la censure qui a été
durcie et plus punissant jusqu'à 15 en
prison toute l'attention diffusion
d'informations mensongères sur l'armée
moi j'ai une question de béotien comme
le disait laetitia tout est un peu
étrange mais est ce que c'est vraiment
tenable en 2022 de pouvoir comme ça
restreindre et censurer une forme
d'information à l'échelle d'un pays
continent c'est une excellente question
à laquelle je n'ai pas de réponse mais
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
voit que les gens
dialoguant et passant le plus que de
plus en plus de temps sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment pour s'informer
notamment pour dialoguer sur des plate
forme centralisée d'accord si les états
commencent à contrôler et à réguler
l'accès à ces plateformes bah finalement
vous arriver à créer des bulles
informationnel alors qu'ils sont jamais
totalement étanche parce qu'en fait
totalement étanche ça voudrait dire que
les russes très capable de déconnecter
leur internet du reste du monde ce qui
vous font les chinois n'ont les chinois
ne déconnecte pas leur internet les
chinois ont des portes d'entrée et de
sortie très précise que les russes
rêvent de faire depuis trois ans mais il
n'y arrive pas parce qu'ils
voient là mais ils ont un des réseaux en
fait les plus bas d'europe pardonnez moi
l'expression mais des plus bordélique du
monde parce qu'il a été créé dans les
années 90 dans des conditions
extrêmement chaotique ce qui fait qu'il
a difficilement contrôlable au niveau
infrastructurel au niveau du flux de
données mais par contre sur la question
des plateformes on voit que depuis une
semaine le gouvernement russe est
clairement en train d'organiser un
véritable black out informationnel
puisque les dernières voix d'opposition
qui étaient par exemple la radio écho
moscou et qui est la radio echo de
moscou caisse 2,91 dostal à la
télévision d'opposition qui qui qui émet
depuis de nombreuses années ont été
fermées il n'y a aujourd'hui plus en
russie aucune voix pour porter un
discours j'aime pas le mot mais
alternatif à celui final
il n'aura et casey est enfin bon bref
aujourd'hui c'est devenu très très
compliqué on voit que les journalistes
occidentaux quittent en masse la russie
tout simplement parce que exercer leur
métier devient très compliqué frédéric
charillon est-ce qu'en perdant cette
guerre de la communication
la russie n'a pas perdu une guerre
d'influencé pour les dix vingt trente
années à venir alors à la fois je rends
tâche ce constat et je partage aussi ce
qui vient d'être dit à l'instant c'est à
dire la tension avec l'occident
alors d'abord oui c'est je me suis mise
à le brancher sur la cette question dans
l'ain en faisant cet ouvrage que vous
avez la gentillesse de mentionner c'est
à dire que vladimir poutine a construit
pendant pratiquement 20 ans depuis qu'il
est arrivé au pouvoir un instrument
d'influencé il a mis beaucoup de moyens
sur la table pour ça des médias qui ont
été fermés d'ailleurs récemment mais
aussi des relais il a repris pied avec
dans de vieux réseaux en europe centrale
en europe balkaniques et également
ailleurs et ça lui réussit c'est plutôt
pas mal il avait trouvé des relais il
avait trouvé des soutiens
regardons même dans notre campagne
électorale en france la difficulté
qu'ont ses principaux soutiens à
rétropédaler aujourd'hui sans d'ailleurs
le faire le faire totalement donc ça
prouve que ça prouve que cette politique
d' influence elle allait porter ses
fruits et voilà qu'il sacrifie tout ça
d'un coup pratiquement en tout cas dans
le monde occidental pour
passer de la guerre d'influencé rigueur
tout court en réalité ce qui lui vaut la
fermeture de ces médias ce qui me vaut
nous vivons une grande difficulté assez
à ses soutiens et c'est donc de ce point
de vue là il a annoncé en quelque sorte
un type d' influence en tout cas dans le
monde occidental ça veut pas dire qu'il
a totalement perdu cette guerre d'
influence d'abord est ce qu'on ne voit
le gars sait il ya que ses soutiens
quand même et puis le toute la
rhétorique de vladimir poutine
aujourd'hui c'est celle d'un monde post
occidental il les rejoint en cela par la
chine aujourd'hui encore le ministère
chinois des affaires étrangères a
réitéré l'alliance avec la russie la
chine a condamné la russie elle s'est
abstenue ce qui est déjà
ce qui est déjà une sorte de d'entre eux
deux mais elle a réitéré son souhait
malien sonné avec là aussi sans limite
une alliance au nom des mythix en ligne
itunes itunes et sans licence une
parenthèse là-dessus la grande question
qu'on se pose aujourd'hui c'est les
cantonnant les chinois ont affiché cela
ouverture des jeux olympiques aux côtés
de vladimir poutine il ya quelques
semaines et ce qu'ils savaient ce qu'ils
étaient tenus informés dans la lumière
poutine qui se passerait des choses
comme ça en ukraine c'est la question
qu'on peut se poser aujourd'hui mais en
tout cas ils sont partis sur une
rhétorique d'un monde post occidentale
avec une animosité très forte vis-à-vis
du monde occidental est donc aujourd'hui
ce n'est plus public occidental que l'on
cherche à convaincre dans cette guerre
d'influencé on cherche à conserver le
soutien de certains pays du sud ou en
tout cas la neutralité que certains pays
du sud et puis le soutien de cette
alliance russo chinoises à la grande et
pour finir sur cette question de
l'influencé la grande question qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi la
lumière poutine at il après vingt ans de
construction de réseaux d influence
après partout dans le monde qui obtenait
quand même certains succès tranquille le
risque aujourd'hui
d'isoler d'une part la russie de tout le
monde occidental ça on peut le
comprendre si sa rhétorique et des anti
occidental mais pourquoi aussi continuer
le risque de mettre totalement le pays
entre les mains de la chine parce que
plus les sanctions occidentales vont se
resserrer plus c'est la chine qui pourra
pallier à tout cela et il met son pays
entre les mains de la chine ce qui est
tout de même étonnant alors on finira
notre émission répondant précisément à
ces questions qui sont évidemment très
intéressante mais j'aimerais juste qu'on
fasse quand même un point sur la
question du jour le terme du jour celui
de corridor humanitaire
annoncée par l'agencé tass évidemment
proche du kremlin ce matin l'ouverture
par la russie de corridors humanitaires
une annonce qui a surpris tout le monde
beaucoup de monde et on va avant
d'interpréter ce geste si c'en est un on
va d'abord expliquer à nos
téléspectateurs de quoi il s'agit avec
steve jourdain
on revoit on se dit alors vous avez un
couloir que commence à se dessiner c'est
quoi un couloir humanitaire bas très
concrètement c'est une zone isolée des
combats qui permet précisément d'évacuer
des civils c'est une zone isolée des
combats qui permet d'acheminer de faire
passer du matériel médical et des vivres
vers les populations juridiquement le
couloir humanitaire c'est une obligation
au regard du droit international
humanitaire c'est dans la convention de
genève c'est dans l'article 23 à
l'article 23 qui stipule la chose
suivante chaque partie accordera le
libre passage de tout envoi de
médicaments et de matériel sanitaire et
des vivres indispensables de vêtements
et fortifiant même et c'est important de
même à la population et demie mathieu
mais alors là en l'occurrence les
couloirs humanitaires proposé par les
russes ne respectent pas tous les
critères du droit international non
parce que pour qu'il y ait couillet
couloir humanitaire il faut au moins
deux choses il faut un cessez le feu
dans la zone concernée un cessez le feu
tout au long du parcours il faut aussi
un accord entre les belligérants
ces conditions ne sont pour l'heure pas
respectée puisque les six couloirs
humanitaires qui ont été proposées par
les russes ont été mis en place de
manière unilatérale décrétée côté russe
sans l'accord des autorités ukrainiennes
cet accord entre les parties est
indispensable mathieu il m'enseignait
aussi dans la convention de genève c'est
à l'article 17 les parties au conflit
s'efforceront de conclure des
arrangements locaux pour l'évacuation
d'une zone assiégée ou en cercle et on
comprend mieux mathieu pourquoi les
ukrainiens ont vu et bien dans ces
corridors humanitaires un piège tendu
par moscou il ya des enjeux très concret
un des enjeux de vie et de mort pour les
civils mais aussi beaucoup d'enjeu de
communication vous l'évoquez tout à
l'heure alors juste au moment où on se
parle et alors que s'achève le troisième
round de négociations russo ukrainiennes
au bélarus le négociateur ukrainien on
n'a pas encore de détails mais fait par
de petits progrès sur ces couloirs
humanitaires
christian carion à quoi joue vladimir
poutine sur ces couloirs humanitaires et
s qui fonctionneront dans les deux sens
parce qu on a aussi appris qu'en fait
beaucoup débouché en russie précisément
un endroit où n'ont pas envie de se
retrouver les réfugiés chrétiens alors
ils jouent à semer le trouble chez
l'adversaire et à fracturer le camp
occidental et accessoirement à
ridiculiser le chef d'état français
emmanuel macron qui d'ailleurs a réagi
très vivement
parce que monsieur poutine s'inspire
directement de ce qui s'est passé en
syrie et c'est véritablement effrayant
en syrie dans le siège d'alep il ya eu
des couloirs humanitaires mais qu'est ce
que signifie un couloir humanitaire pour
les russes absolument pas la même chose
que pour nous pour les russes un couloir
humanitaire ça signifie évacuer le
maximum de population civile avec un
délai afin que le jour dit ou cesse
l'évacuation on puisse considérer tous
ceux qui restent dans la ville comme des
combattants et donc à ce titre le
bombardement intensif soit autorisée
puisque on aurait conditionnel autoriser
les civils à fuir justement par le boire
humanitaire c'est une façon de s'en
laver les mains c'est une façon de
ravager le terrain et de s'emparer de
tout ça c'est le premier point et
deuxièmement
effectivement les russes ont proposé
d'aller aux ukrainiens d'aller vers la
biélorussie ou vers la russie vous
imaginez le rêve même pour des gens
totalement désespéré écrasés sous les
bombes c'est inacceptable invivable
quant à l'évacuation vers la pologne
elle est possible les trains
fonctionnent encore il ya des services
de bus la croix rouge est présente
l'union européenne a mis des moyens mais
enfin entre kharkiv et lviv et de livres
à la pologne ça fait quand même une
sacrée distance donc et on ne peut pas
s'organiser c'est un média pas de
couloir en u en zone de la saison et là
où le kremlin était c'est là qu'on voit
si vous voulez la signature de la de la
méchanceté c'est que le kremlin a osé
dire que c'était une proposition du
président français que d'installer ses
couloirs humanitaires la qui allaient
vers la biélorussie et la russie
ce qui évidemment est extrêmement
blessant pour emmanuel macron parce
qu'il n'a absolument pas fait cette
proposition laetitia justement fait
pencher là dessus ces problèmes de
débriefing j'allais dire des changes
entre la nuit à poutine emmanuel macron
on se rend compte que finalement la
diplomatie est interconnecté et
dépendante de la communication c'est à
dire que par définition la diplomatie
doit être sue et donc on doit faire
savoir et communiqué aux opinions
publiques les positions des différents
négociateurs et la vladimir poutine
quand il dit et qu'il ment de façon
éhontée en dix ans et emmanuel macron
qui a eu cette idée il a deux objectifs
déjà affaibli dans l'opinion publique
française ça c'est une spécialité des
russes il ils envoient et elles
diffusent des fakes news notamment ou
alors des vrais un des vrais muse
notamment la photo de françois fillon
vous savez au comex là dans son
entreprise avec le drapeau français ce
sont les russes qui ont diffusé cette
cette image pour objectif il avait la
défiance encore plus grande des français
vis-à-vis de leurs dirigeants politiques
c'est exactement le même objectif qu'ils
ont quand il envoie ce mensonge alors la
saga sa part canalisé vivement les lisez
bien sûr réagi parce que c'est une
guerre de communication entre les
opinions publiques l'elysée réagi pour
quoi pour essayer de solidifier
l'opinion publique française et
occidentale et européennes mais
maintenant ils se sont fait avoir une
fois le camoufler de cet échange et de
la rencontre promise entre joe biden et
vladimir poutine qui finalement dans la
nuit et démentis et pire enfin je veux
dire deux jours trois jours après on en
manquait romain oui mais la guerre c'est
le jeudi enfin vous voyez cet
enchaînement et ça a été catastrophique
pour l'image d'emmanuel macron donc
maintenant l'elysée a bien compris ils
solidifie à chaque fois ils envoient un
débriefing détaillé de toutes les
conversations que le président français
avec vladimir poutine et nous français
finalement nous nous rendons compte mais
bien tard que nous sommes quand je
disais tout à l'heure dans deux systèmes
totalement différent de communication et
que les russes sont emprisonnés dans une
propagande mais ça date pas d'hier ça
donne pas de la gare d'uccle phase où
les soviétiques la propagande était
était faux en chine également et j'ai
l'impression qu'on on est sidéré par
fonctionnent les russes mais il faut
bien comprendre que sans cette guerre
informationnelle encore une fois tous
les démentis de l'elysée très
honnêtement ne passeront pas cette
frontière étanche s'est insurgé c'est un
sujet très profond pour éveiller à mâcon
c'est à se demander s'il faut continuer
à jouer ce rôle d'intervenir puisque les
pays totalitaires en particulier de
l'héritage soviétique frappe d'abord les
gentils et puis ils préfèrent discuter
avec des méchants donc nous la france
nous sommes dans le rôle du médiateur
profondément gentil qui veut éviter le
carnage humain et humanitaire et c'est
là que les russes frappe le plus à la
limite ils épargnent davantage des
américains c'est ce qu'on écoute on
écoute la réaction courroucée de damon
macro
et donc nous ce qu'on dit simplement
c'est qu'il faut que les acteurs de
l'humanitaire puisse intervenir qui dit
donc des trêves complète quand ils
interviennent pour mettre en protection
les femmes les enfants les hommes qui
doivent être protégés et pouvoir les
sortir de la zone de conflit donc c'est
pas simplement des couloirs qui sont
tout de suite menacé et c'est pas ce
discours hypocrites qui consiste à dire
on va aller protéger les gens pour les
emmener en russie
n'est pas sérieux c'est du cynisme
morale et politique
met insupportable
frédéric charillon ça fait partie de
cette guerre des communiqués cette
guerre des mots ça fait partie de cette
grande influence que vous décriviez je
t'adore oui oui oui et puis ça veut dire
je souscris à ce qui vient des petits
également les 10 alors pas et tous les
autres mais ça veut dire aussi d'autres
choses d'abord ça veut dire que c'est
une tradition si un peu des régimes
autoritaires on ne discute pas pour pour
aboutir à un compromis ou à une solution
on discute pour gagner du temps voilà
pour diviser l'adversaire n'a attendu
concrètement de ces couloirs
humanitaires
il faut essayer il faut essayer bien sûr
d'obtenir des choses mais on les
obtiendra plus par le rapport de force
notamment économiques et autres que par
les attentes même geste d'humanité de la
part de l'avenir vous dis donc
avec la syrie oui c'est exact on
retrouve les mêmes méthodes de combat
attend il faut partir je crois de leçons
qu'on a qu'on a prises ou si on les a
pas appris c'est
dommage mais un
la russie ne discute pas pour faire du
sud donnant donnant et pour gagner du
temps 2 il faut pas s'attendre à ce que
la lumière cousiné envie de faire de
cadeau à emmanuel macron il sait très
bien que il sait très bien qu'à une
élection en france c'est très bien qui
mêle makoun n'est pas le candidat qui
lui est plus favorable aucune envie de
lui faire de cadeaux et puis on s'est
subitement cessé très embêtant parce que
ça veut dire que son souk el baz
négocier et à partir du moment où on a
affaire à des propositions ou des actes
qui sont démenties tout de suite après y
compris d'ailleurs dans les mains
tendues a été cité aussi on dit oui on
veut bien discuter avec avec hayden qui
après non on veut pas discuter
là aujourd'hui il attribue des propos et
modèles macro qu'il n'a pas qu'il n'a
pas tenues donc c'est très difficile
alors on disait tout à l'heure il veut
diviser les européens oui est juste
aussi un mot là-dessus là où ça va être
très compliqué c'est que nous ne sommes
pas encore entrés dans le dur de la
détermination des européens pour le
moment les européens ont fait ce qu'ils
savent faire c'est un petit peu méchant
de dire ça mais c'est à dire par les
annonces et et faire des promesses alors
très bien il ya un réveil à une
évolution de la position allemande tout
ça est très bien mais on est encore dans
la phase la plus facile c'est dans la
salle delà de l'émotion de la bonne
volonté juste vous allez on sanctionner
nous allons livrer des armes il va
falloir les acheminer il va falloir
aussi savoir le coût de ses ambitions
pour nous et là je pense que la dernière
coupe chine continue de penser que les
héros p1 seront faibles et des visées
j'ai bien une autre question c'est une
autre question qui veut que vont devoir
affronter les européens c'est qu'ils dit
corridors humanitaires ou exil ou
réfugiées en tout cas voilà dit qu'il
paye un certain nombre d'ukrainiens vont
venir en ordre il y en a déjà un million
et demi visiblement qui qui auraient fui
le pays selon gérait borel le
représentant de l'union européenne pour
les affaires étrangères il faut
s'attendre à ce que est ce que l'europe
accueille 5 millions de réfugiés
ukrainien sidim atteignait est ce que ça
peut faire vaciller
la belle unité qu'on a vu dans ses douze
premiers jours de guerre avec cette
unité affichée sur les sanctions cette
unité affichée sur sur la doctrine de
défense immunitaire est ce que cette
question des réfugiés peut faire
vaciller cet ensemble
pro très certainement alors après reste
à voir si les motions perdurera ou pas
mais il est clair que ça peut ça peut
questionner faut bien rappeler que la
crise migratoire de 2015 et celle qui a
entraîné le break cité la sortie du
royaume uni de l'union européenne donc
effectivement c'est une fragilité des
européens que cette question migratoire
et le contexte politique en europe n'a
pas changé au point de pouvoir se dire
que les crises migratoires sont derrière
nous et que les choses ont évolué mais
il regarde un peu différent faut bien le
reconnaître qu'ils sont désolés sur ces
réfugiés craignant ses vrais réfugiés
et c'est toute l'incertitude c'est ton à
cette situation et ses divisions sur la
question migratoire qui plus est avec un
nouveau un nouveau chancelier à la tête
de l'allemagne on n'est plus en présence
d'angela merkel donc avec aussi une
nouvelle approche côté allemand et de
l'autre côté on à l'émotion le fait que
c'est une guerre aux portes de l'europe
et finalement la perception des
populations est différente par rapport à
ce qu'elle était en 2015 donc c'est très
compliqué de savoir aujourd'hui ce qui
va se passer et en intérieur ou la
gestion des réfugiés et doit être vu
aussi à l'aune de l'évolution du conflit
à ma connaissance le seul cas où on a
des masses tel de
migrants chassés par une guerre c'est le
cas de la syrie avec 3,5 même 3,8
millions de syriens qui vivent sur le
sol de la turquie et ça se passe pas
toujours très bien et la turquie est
impliquée fortement sur le terrain
militaire syrien contre la russie
d'ailleurs mais si on prend cette
comparaison c'est la seule dans le taux
n'est à face est la seule dont on
dispose il faut bien voir que si on
arrive à 3 millions voire plus de
réfugiés ukrainien en pologne en
moldavie en roumanie etc on va avoir un
problème qui est le suivant quelles
seront les conditions dans lesquelles
ces réfugiés qui avaient des logements
des emplois une culture des écoles des
villages des papiers d'identité pourront
retourner chez eux alors que les russes
il serait encore comme conquérant
ravageur entre guillemets au culot donc
ça m'occupe on s'impose un problème
énorme et c'est bien ça le calcul des
russes ce ne sont pas des migrants qui
sont déracinés ce sont des victimes de
la guerre provoquée par la russie et là
c'est véritablement intentionnel ils ne
pourront ces millions de dhs ukrainien
malheureux retourner chez eux que
lorsque des conditions d'une paix
tolérable et supportable et vivable
seront rétablis donc c'est là que les
russes garde les mains si vous voulez y
compris sur ces pauvres gens racine et
et c'est véritablement mon avis très
inquiétant c'est plus comme ça que
l'union européenne va avoir des
problèmes que sur la question de
l'accueil d'accueil tu t'es venu mener
c'est quoi le prochain coup devenir pro
alors je suis pas dans sa tête
je n'aime pas faire ce qu'on appelle de
la criminologie c'est à dire à ce poste
de voilà 2 de sciences un peu occultes
qui consisterait à essayer de savoir ce
qui se passe au kremlin parce qu'en fait
la veille la vérité c'est qu'on n'en
sait pas grand chose maintenant on peut
utiliser l'histoire et on peut utiliser
le passé pour essayer de comprendre les
erreurs du présent et pour essayer de
comprendre finalement oui quelles vont
être les prochains les prochains les
prochains coups alors j'en sais rien
mais
déjà on peut voir une chose très
intéressante qui est que les russes ont
clairement mais estimé la puissance de
leurs armes et la réaction des
occidentaux bref il ya un vrai problème
là chez les russes sur du contexte
d'appréciation du contexte de la part
des décideurs et hier il ya un texte
très intéressant hier ou avant-hier qui
a été publié par un journaliste qu'il a
obtenues d'un analyste du fsb
catastrophé qui écrit et qui dit enfin
voilà qui est choqué par ce qui se passe
et le type dit en gros nous quand on
nous a demandé de préparer cette
invasion cet exercice bon on a cru que
c'était encore une commande lambda de je
sais pas qui est c'est donc on sait pas
embêter on n'a pas voulu avoir de
problème on a fait le travail à minimum
et on a envoyé vers le haut et ça c'est
très intéressant parce que c'est ce que
un de mes collègues appellent le zèle
des petits chefs qui est quelque chose
qui est très présent dans la culture
bureaucratique russe où finalement c'est
quelque chose qui existe depuis l'époque
soviétique qui vient de la bureaucratie
soviétique et qui est si vous voulez
l'idée de ne pas avoir trop de problèmes
en faisant remonter des informations ça
veut pas dire qu'on manque d'exécution
plutôt qu'une culture de réflexion
exactement et ça veut pas dire comment
ça veut dire qu'on va
pas essayer d'avoir des problèmes avec
le patron si jamais les choses n'ont pas
bien bon si vous faites ça un échelon
deux échelons ça va mais si vous avez 10
échelons entre l'analyse par exemple et
le kremlin vous imaginez bien que quand
ça arrive à la 10 mars sur le stand sur
le bureau de vladimir poutine ça n'a
plus du tout la même tête que
la réalité et ça si ça intéresse les
téléspectateurs ils peuvent livre un
livre qui date des années 80 d'un auteur
soviétique s'appelle alexandre zinoviev
le livre ça fait l'homo sovieticus et
dans ce livre il ya un chapitre qui
s'appelle la culture du rapport qui est
très rigolo où il explique justement
comment est ce que faire des rapports
c'est aussi surtout se débarrasser des
problèmes élevé dans une bureaucratie
qui reste extrêmement corrompu comme
l'est la russie d'aujourd'hui on
comprend qu'il ya un problème de
mécanismes là et que aujourd'hui poutine
en paye le prix eh bien merci beaucoup
pour ce conseil de lecture je vous en
donne un autre qui est le livre guerre
d'influencé des états à la conquête des
esprits le livre de frédéric charillon
merci à tous merci à vous si di natali
sa merci avoue christian ma carrière
merci a vous d une monnier merci à vous
on est ici à d'avoir participé à ce
débat